Hello, everyone, I just landed in Berlin for
the first time of my life, at I've already
fallen in love with this city.
So my name is Hui Jing, and I go by Jing as
well.
I love emoji.
We have 2,666 emojis right now with which
to express ourselves, so I'm going to introduce
myself with them.
I'm from Malaysia - very proud of that - and
I used to play basketball full-time.
Basketball actually helped kick-start my web
career, so you can ask me about that later
if you're interested.
My inordinate love of CSS is what compels
me to speak and write about this topic, and
it's essentially what put me here on the stage
in front of all of you today.
I also happen to be a Mozilla tech speaker
which is an initiative by Mozilla that supports
technical evangelists in communities around
the world by providing resources and funding.
What do you think about when you hear the
word "typography"?
It used to be a niche subject, something only
artsy creative types cared about, but these
days, it seems that typographic stories have
been making their way into mainstream news.
We have big brand names like National Geographic
and Netflix talking about their redesigns.
The Microsoft font Calibri was a crucial proof
of evidence that forged forgery in a Supreme
Court case in Pakistan.
What is typography?
Plenty of definitions out there.
I personally always refer back to this one
by Gerrit Noordzij that typography is writing
with pre-Fabricant letters, a type of grapheme
which is the smallest unit of a writing system
of any given language.
Writing systems are visual representations
of verbal communication.
It's a means to record whatever we say in
our respective languages for storage and transport.
The world is very diverse when it comes to
language and culture so it's natural there
are many different writing systems use writing
around the planet.
The majority use alphabets.
This is a small sampling of different alphabets
from different languages.
The Hebrew alphabet own has 22 letters.
The Ukrainian alphabet slightly larger with
33 letters, seven more letters than the English
alphabet which only has 26.
The point I'm trying to make here is that
alphabetic writing systems utilise a small
set of letters to formulate all the words
a language needs for the purposes of communication.
Chinese is a bit different.
It is a logographic language.
Chinese characters number in the tens of thousands
and each character is a unique glyph that
can express meaning on their own or be used
in combination with other glyphs.
Let's look at a few examples to illustrate
this point.
The word "communication", with this is an
English word.
You need 13 letters to spell it.
Chinese we can express the same in two characters.
We can say [Chinese spoken].
I'm going to butcher this word, please excuse
me, German speak ers, Backpfeifengesicht.
This is a German word of 18 characters, and,
in Chinese, we can say something similar - [Chinese
spoken].
Grianghrafadóireachta, an Irish word, but,
again, this Chinese, two characters is enough.
You can say [Chinese spoken].
Chinese is a pretty concise language, if you
ask me.
Although a large SWAT of the world reads mostly
from left to right, writing as many as can
go in all directions.
Modern-day use scripts so languages like Japanese
and Korean are read from right to left.
Mongolian uses vertical writing but read from
left to right.
Han characters are sometimes called square
characters because each is composed in a uniform
square.
This allows Chinese to be read efficiently
whether typeset vertically or horizontally.
Chinese text can be typeset into neat rows
and columns.
If you don't understand Chinese, you may not
know which direction the text is going.
Now, the Chinese script is set to have developed
independently from proto-sinaitic scripts
which are the origins of -- this is why Indo-European
writing systems are different from those of
east Asia.
As different alphabetic writing systems branched
out from the Phoenician alphabet, the letter
forms evolved and changed.
The appearance of letter forms were influenced
by the tools used to create them.
The earliest letters were sans serif when
done with a hard read pen.
When transition made with a square implement,
the letters developed serifs.
In the middle ages, scribes and copyists who
used quill pens had to develop more efficient
styles of writing.
Chinese characters have evolved greatly since
the earliest glyphs were scratched into animal
shells and bones since back as 1600BC.
The
ancient rulers who used them to consult with
the various higher powers, important questions
about things like agriculture, weather, warfare,
things that royalty cared about.
The key implement of Chinese writing is the
brush.
Calligraphy was and still is one of the most
highly regarded Chinese art, and the work
of famous calligraphers were used for carving
wood blocks for printing.
Type faces used for printing Chinese publications
can be broadly categorised into the four families.
[On screen].
A bit different from Latin-based scripts.
Chinese typefaces are extremely challenging
to create.
Simply due to the volume of glyphs required.
An average number for glyphs clocks in around
35,000 glyphs.
This is an article that covers the process
of creating a Chinese font.
It is an interesting read because it goes
into how much effort is needed to design and
create a Chinese typeface.
To be used as body copy, it will need a minimum
of 7,000 glyphs if you're using simplified
Chinese or 13,000 glyphs if you're going for
traditional Chinese.
That's still a lot of glyphs, hence Chinese
fonts are almost always designed by teams
over periods of years.
Now, the web is less than 30 years old, and
because it is a completely new medium, it's
only natural that people try to reconcile
it with something familiar like print.
However, there's an additional degree of separation
between the creator and the final output.
As such, we cannot have the same set of expectations
when it comes to handling the web as a medium.
This is a medium where you cannot directly
manipulate the canvas, in this case, the viewport
of my browser.
Instead, what we do is we write code and instructions
to the browser, to tell them how we want our
designs to be rendered.
With the release of CSS Grid last year, it
seems we've hit another milestone for web
sign.
Jen Simmons, creator of Layout Land, drew
a parallel between the evolution from metal
letter press to photo-based paste-up with
this evolution, from floats to grid.
Modern CSS gives us a wider vocabulary with
which to communicate with the browser.
So we can leverage these new capabilities
that browsers now have for better art direction,
more creative layouts, and fresher designs
that break out of the cookie-cutter moulds
we're so used to seeing on the web.
Now, as an athlete, I cannot help but draw
parallels between my work and my experience
with my sport.
CSS is a holistic technology in that, even
though you can use properties in isolation,
the full power of CSS shines through when
properties are used in combination, so you
can treat this talk like a scouting report.
Where I profile some of the most promising
players on team layout, and how they can work
really well together to handle certain situations
but really, at the end of the day, I got Jackie
mentioned earlier, you have to find a solution
that best works for your use case.
Now, it was purely by chance that I started
exploring vertical layouts on the web.
You see, I was stuck in a crowded subway train
a few years ago, and I was inadvertently peering
over the shoulder of guy standing over me
and he was reading a Chinese novel on his
phone.
It was typeset horizontally.
This is when I first thought to myself: a
traditional vertical layout would work great
on a phone.
I wondered if this can be done on the web?
Turns out, it can.
And really well too.
These are websites that have won a web award
given no those who are willing to that I can
up the challenge of ushering in the variety
al text by utilising new typesetting standards
with modern CSS.
Some of you may find this hard to believe,
but vertical text was supported by Internet
Explorer since version 5.5.
They were using an earlier version of the
specification which originated from SPG.
Chrome started in 2010 and safari and Opera
in 2013, and Firefox in 2015.
But although vertical writing is native to
east Asian languages, that doesn't exclude
you from using vertical texts simply because
you doesn't design for those languages.
If anything, the fact that browsers can better
support vertical text allows us to draw design
inspiration for more sources than before.
For horizontal-only languages, you wouldn't
want to lay out text vertically for long passages,
understandably, but there are subtle ways
that you can insert vertical text in your
designs to add flavour without compromising
the reading experience.
An example would be labels for card-based
designs - so popular.
Or tags for blog posts.
Cases where text is not critical to understanding
the main content.
You could even use them for head ers for sections
on long scrolling pages.
You could perhaps use them for small-screen
navigation.
There are a lot of possibilities here.
But vertical layouts are not a new thing.
It's just that the web hadn't reached a level
of maturity that could do them well until
recently.
For example, this is a mixed layout multi-lingual
magazine cover from Japan.
This is totally doable on the web today.
This poster is by Edward, one of Europe's
most influential poster artists in the 19
thirties.
Another with some diagonal layout going on
there.
This one is a vintage cover of architectural
design magazine with this radial text layout.
Then I came across this particular book cover
for the Craftsmen, and I thought, okay, let's
do pencils.
Specifically, let's do these vertical pencils
with text in them on the web.
Now, preparing for this talk, I got a bit
carried away with the sports analogy and ended
up being sidetracked by creating CSS trading
cards because I have the attention span of
a five-year-old!
Anyhow, let's start off with something reasonably
familiar.
In this case, CSS Transforms.
Even though Transforms are used for animation,
static Transforms can be useful too.
My basic strategy was to start off with an
audit list, and each pencil being a list item.
Then styling each item to look like a pencil.
And then lay them out vertically.
So the second and third points are pretty
closely intertwined.
The markup for this is very basic.
The additional P tag inside this list item
is for styling purposes because I only have
two pseudo elements to play with, and that's
not enough for a pure CSS pencil.
The key property for the visual effect we
see here is borders.
The border property in my opinion is an unrated
CSS property.
If you read CSS Secrets or watched her brilliant
talk on the humble border radius, you may
already know this, but the tips of the pencils
are made using the CSS triangle technique
which makes use of the fact that borders meet
as diagonals.
There are four 2D transforms available to
us, and we will use the rotate transform to
get the pencils vertical.
The tricky part about using transforms is
that you have to keep in mind the transform
origin, and how the browser deals with transforms
to begin with.
Transforms bringing the element in question
into its own layer, and takes it out of the
normal document flow.
So, if you're trying to rotate elements that
are supposed to be part of a larger layout,
which is pretty much all the time, you might
end up with unwanted overflows or overlaps.
A friend of my mine tried to transform an
entire website and discovered so many interesting
things that it warranted a 20-minute talk
in our local CSS meet-up.
What other options do we have for vertical
layouts?
Well, the outcome of my research into typesetting
Chinese vertically on the web, led me to discover
the existence of the writing modes specification.
This specification covers all sorts of international
writing systems replaces the Unicode and BD
direction features in CSS 2.1 and introduces
a number of rules and properties required
to properly support vertical text in CSS.
This is what happens to your text when different
values of writing mode are applied.
The default is horizontal top-to-bottom, and
to change the direction to vertical, we use
vertical RL, or vertical LR.
When we rotate twelve, it is not only the
lines that change direction, because each
line actually contains individual letters
or characters.
And they have an orientation as well.
For text orientation, the value of this property
is initially mixed because browsers are smart
enough to figure out which languages can be
typeset both vertically and horizontally and
in one direction only.
Chinese characters, for example, will always
be displayed upright, while horizontal-only
languages like English or German, will have
their characters rotated with vertical, so
the text orientation property lets you control
this and make the characters upright or sideways
if that is what you want.
Text-combined upright addresses numerals or
abbreviations in vertical text, it allows
us to fit them into the width of one character
and display them upright in no browser supports
the last one, the digits value yet.
This value allows us to dictate how many digits
or letters are acceptable to be squeezed into
this little space.
Reasonably, the range allowed is between two
to four characters but for now, we only have
the all value.
There is no limit.
So you could put a really long word like,
"Beethoven" and the browser will do it.
It will squish the letters into that single
character space.
Probably not something you want, but you could
always try it out.
Back to pencils.
We will keep the same strategy as before except
the layout in visual styles are essentially
done together.
You will see why in a bit.
No change to the markup.
Here, we apply writing mode first.
Because presently, we still rely heavily on
the physical directions of left, right, top,
with , bottom, when it comes to styling elements.
Hence all the borders used previously have
to be recalibrated because it is not as straightforward
of taking the styling of the Transform's use
case, and call it a day.
No, if you compare the code for this, and
it is a bit lengthy, you will notice that
even though the words are rotated and flowing
from right to left, the direction of margins
and paddings still adhere to our upright perspective.
For example, padding on the left of my pencil
text, I have to apply using padding top.
This sort of confuses me a lot.
But luckily, we have an up and coming new
player on Team Layout - the CSS Logical Properties.
It uses logical properties like block start
and block end, and inline start and end which
are relative to the block flow of the page,
allowing us to use the same code regardless
of writing mode.
I highly suggest reading Rachel Andrew's in-depth
article on CSS in Smashing Maczine to gain
a better understanding of this relatively
new spec.
The first public working draft of the specification
was published in December last year, and I'm
eager to see it developed and more widely
implemented.
We can't talk about layout without talking
about Flexbox, and Flexbox is definitely an
all-star player on team layout.
If you try to brilliant out the specification,
it's about 87 pages long, and that's a good
reason for that.
It defines a new layout mode designed for
laying out complex applications and web pages.
It is probably the first property specifically
designed to do layout on the web.
Let's have more pencils.
Many, many more pencils, and I want them to
be a mixture of vertical and horizontal pencils.
So this is becoming a larger scale layout
situation.
Flexbox is capable of handling this.
It is very versatile like that.
You can use it for small components for a
bigger scale layout.
The markup is similar to previous examples,
just multiplied lots of times.
These are a mix of vertical and horizontal
with different colours so you can see which
way they are being laid out.
Flexbox can do space distribution and content
alignment like nothing we've seen before.
Flex children can be laid out in any flow
direction - left word, right word, downwards
or even upwards if that is what you want.
Display order can be reversed or rearranged,
although this does have accessibility implications
and should be used with caution.
Items within the flex container are laid out
like a long daisy chain.
Even if they are wrap around, there is no
relationship between the rows and columns.
It is one really long row or one really long
column that wrapped around itself.
So a property that controls the flow direction
is aptly named "flex-direction", and, with
this, we can actually reorder the flow of
content, so the default value is row.
You can see based on the colours that it has
changed the way it is flowing.
We have another other options as well.
We can do flex-direction column, and you can
see it is now this way, going downward.
Column reverse makes it go upwards.
So you're not limited to just left and right
which is actually the title of my talk.
I want to emphasise this modifies the visual
order and not the source order of the flex
items.
Screenreaders and keyboard controls will respect
the source order.
If Flexbox is an all star, Grid is shaping
up to be a Hall of Fame level.
It let's us do things that were previously
impossible or highly untenable.
Now, I never talk about Grid without quoting
Rachel Andrew: grid works from the container
in while other methods start with the item.
Think about how we did an item in a pre-Grid
era.
When an approach for creating such a layout
is with an inline-block, so you would set
the display of your items to inline-block
and give them a width of a third of the container.
It is almost the same if you use floats because
you also need to set a width on each item.
If you use Flexbox to ensure that the items
line up in three columns, you have to make
sure that the flex basis is also a third of
the container.
The properties applying always go on the item.
So, for all three of the techniques I've just
described, there is no grid.
It just looks that way because we force the
items to line up with each other.
But with Grid, the Grid is real.
We define its rows and columns, and then we
place items on the grid wherever we want to.
We are freed from the limitation of elements
having to line up next to each other all the
time.
This means that our layouts can now be canonically
non-sequential, don't have to mess around
with positioning or other workarounds that
we have to do for vertical spacing.
Here, I have a six by six grid with six grid
items arbitrarily placed anywhere.
And Grid makes it really simple and intuitive
to have vertical white space in our design,
so you essentially just design which row and
which column you want your item to be.
It is just co-ordinates, so, if you change
the row, I can just move that soccer ball
down the grid.
So it is really intuitive to have vertical
white space in our designs with CSS Grid.
Like I mentioned, there's a lot of great graphing
design we can draw inspiration from.
This is from a book - butchering the pronunciation!
- this is a striking design with bold black
borders and content aligned in different configurations.
If we want this design on the web, some team
work will need to be involved.
The code is abridged to show mainly the layout,
but even the gear and arrows can be made with
your pure CSS, a box-shadow trick.
In order to align the content of each Grid
child without disrupting the rendering of
the thick black borders, we need to make each
Grid child a flex parent.
By default, the value of a grid item's alignment
is stretch, where it fills up the entire space
of the Grid correctly.
Once you apply an alignment, it will shrink
to fit the content.
Making each grid item of flex container allows
to us use box alignment properties to adjust
the position of the Grid item's content while
keeping the borders at the edge of the Grid.
Another thing that Grid makes a lot easier
is overlap.
We could have achieved an overlap effect with
absolute positioning but removing an element
from the document flow usually brings about
a lot of unwanted consequences.
With Grid replacement, it is easily achieved
without disrupting the layout at all.
This is from English Painter, a new practical
treaties on three primitive colours.
Totally doable on the web.
Again, the code is abridged, but placement
is a matter of defining which row and column
you would like your element to appear in,
and how many grid cells you would like it
to take up.
It is perfectly acceptable to have multiple
elements occupy the same space on your grid.
This demo was an excuse to play with CSS blend
modes, the same as Photoshop, but it was Adobe
who proposed the specification for it.
This poster
is a rather Grid-able design.
No surprises here that such a design can be
done on the web with CSS Grid.
When we take into account how dynamic the
web is, we are designing for a medium whereby
we have absolutely no control how our designs
will be viewed.
Things get a little bit more interesting.
It is probably a better idea to consider aspect
ratios over absolute dimensions when it comes
to designing web layouts, and the aspect ratio
media query let's us do that natively.
Even though the most common media query we
use, there are 13 media features available
for use as conditions, including height and
orientation.
Somehow, we are just not seeing them being
used that often on the web at the moment.
Aspect ratio media queries are especially
useful for designs that use view port units
but there's no limit on how you wish to use
multiple media query designs fully adaptable.
An often raised concern for features especially
those for layout is browser support.
Nobody wants the site to look broken.
That's legit.
Here is where feature queries come in, and
Oliver, who is coming up after me, will go
into details, so a brief preview to warm him
up for his talk!
This is how a feature query looks like.
The condition checks - if it doesn't, the
entire block is ignored.
That means we start off with a basic layout
that works everywhere.
It means the layout on the styles.
In this manner, the property will still get,
and those that do get a different look, so
we are make use of the C in CSS.
So this image would be the header for a CSS
... that caught my eye.
- for
this particular example, it's an image for
i.e. 11.
More often, the feature query will taken code
that acts as an enhancement to a design that
works in all browsers.
Nothing stopping you from using feature queries
and media queries in combination to cater
for different browsers on different devices.
With feature queries we don't have to revisit
our codebase because the code is not browser-specific.
It is feature-specific.
Once a feature gets shipped, your design will
be updated automatically.
This example makes use of a combination of
feature queries for both Grid and CSS shapes.
For now, Firefox users in the middle don't
get to see the CSS shapes yet.
Once they do, the layout will look like what
Chrome users see at the moment on the right.
It used to be that a new feature or bug fix
would take a long time to ship, and that was
true in the earlier days where browsers were
updated maybe six months, every six months.
These days, the upgrade cycle has shortened
immensely.
This is problemly not the best data visualisation,
but the point is that browsers are being updated
fast and furiously these days.
The favourite to talk about is the release
of CSS Grid.
Most major browsers shipped it in March last
year.
By October, 75 per cent of users around the
world were using a browser that supported
Grid.
Today, that number is 87 per cent.
How amazing is that?
It's so much easier to get enthusiastic about
new CSS features these days because they become
ship and are widely supported quicker now,
and the same goes for bug fixes.
Every major browser engine has an open process
for raising bugs, and raising bugs for a particular
feature sends a signal that people want to
use them.
It is a win by everyone, by taking the time
to submit a bug report, you gain cover points,
you get your bugs fixed, and you make the
web better for all of us.
So, that's it from me.
I just wanted to round off by saying that
you don't need to use any of these techniques
or properties I covered if they don't fit
your use cases today, but know that, when
the time comes, they will all be right here
waiting for you.
Thank you all for your kind attention.
[Applause]